thank you for joining us at noon I'm
John langler another step in the Oakland
A's Saga this morning the team revealed
how a new ballpark on the Las Vegas
Strip would look although we still don't
know specifics on how it'll be paid for
here are the renderings released by the
team today the stadium would sit on nine
acres of land the Tropicana hotel now
calls home it features a partially
retractable roof and could hold up to
thirty thousand fans meanwhile lawmakers
in Carson City are still negotiating the
specific language of a public financing
measure it would pay for part of a 1.5
billion dollar project a mix of County
and state tax breaks and bonds would
cover about 380 million dollars but
against the waiting for the bill to be
introduced